shares of trump-linked spac close up 350
following news of social media deal the
stock of the spat company digital world
acquisition corp skyrocketed on
extremely heavy trading volume after
news of a merger that would launch
former president donald trump's planned
social media platform it surged 357
thursday and trading was halted multiple
times due to volatility
dweck was among the top 10 most popular
names on reddit's wall street bets chat
room even exceeding meme stock game
stops mentions
so so so donald trump
announced announces he's going to be
launching truth what is it called
truth.social i believe truth social
i mean this would be interesting because
i think he's a little too late he had a
lot of momentum he could have you know
people were begging him to do this when
he was still president of the united
states they were like hey get off the
big tech platforms there needs to be an
alternative and for some reason donald
trump waited and waited and waited and
how is he going to tell everyone about
this social media platform i mean some
media organizations are talking about it
but is he going to email everyone about
this yes i mean he will yeah and that
might work and might not but there's a
lot of people disillusioned with them
there's a lot of people that are uh
disenfranchised with the whole trump
movement so will this be as popular as
it would have been if he actually did
this when he was president
i don't think so and you want me to sign
up for parlor and getter and and all of
these platforms like dude i got a
handful already yeah i got twitter i
hate it but i don't really pay much
attention to twitter to be honest like i
really don't that's where i'm at that's
the least platform i use but i was just
talking to ian earlier about minds like
you were mentioning it because there's
so many coming out it's like which one
do i go to do i go to rumble do i go to
gab do i go to go to mines what i mean
what you know i can't be on everything
that's right you go to trump that's a
problem a lot of people are having we
need to build software that bridges all
of them i agree
there's a lot of alternatives float hive
steemit uh
mines
i can name like
about 10 other ones that you know parlor
that people use all the time and and
it's hard because you only have echo
chambers there let's be honest and let's
have a real conversation when you go to
these kind of websites it's the same
people that were kicked off it's the
same people that regurgitate usually the
same talking points and if you want to
go where the people are where the
audience is where the normies are where
the kyle's and karen's are you got to go
on twitter you got to go on facebook you
got to go on instagram and that's where
you reach out the most amount of people
and i think that's why there has been
such a boom in censoring people shutting
them down and trying to just slowly
silence them a little bit when they
counter the narrative twitter is
basically like like the town center
where everybody's talking about stuff
yeah and there are other platforms but
they tend to be
very community based you know if you go
to one platform you'll find a lot of
people who are into you know this
particular culture whereas twitter is
very generalist yeah it's a garbage
platform yeah yeah but they have the
infrastructure they were able to build
the infrastructure because of their
relationships that they had with
governments that were able to give them
an unfair advantage against everyone
else now when we're talking about rumble
or parlor they don't have that same
advantage they don't have the same kind
of infrastructure as all these big tech
companies that could do things that much
faster that much quicker and have the
user base that they don't have so this
is a very difficult situation what's
that dwack what's dwack that's trump's
the thing he merged with d-wack d-wack
they gotta change that name yeah that's
like violating the youtube community
guidelines you think you'd be more
clever with that but trump's rolling out
his truth social to stand up to the
tyranny of big tech oh please i'm not
convinced it would actually i don't
think it i don't think it will and you
want to talk about tyranny apparently
this guy forked mastodon this is what
i've been reading reports on the truth
social is a fork of mastodon and then
they abuse the license they basically
it's agpl which means if you take the
code and you change it you have to make
all your changes public and if they
didn't make all their changes public
then they violated the software license
would you come on dude you're supposed
to be running for president well you're
violating this is insane well that's one
source saying it let's wait because a
lot of you know news around trump has
always been kind of conflated
to say the least so i'm not a trump fan
but i know when i see a headline with
trump in it to
take a step back and be like okay yeah
okay let's do some research on this
let's let's get the textbook out there
let's get let's get the you know let's
get all the resources out there to make
sure this is what they do right with
like freedom phone
so when we had the guy from freedom
phone on all these news stories were
like it's a garbage fake you know
whatever and then i just asked him is it
a knock off and he's like it's a custom
phone and i'm like okay it has it is
based similarly on some of these phones
yes okay so the media is basically
trying to falsely frame what freedom
phone is and act like he's just buying a
phone for 10 bucks and selling it for
20. when in reality it's like they
actually did work developing and setting
we haven't tested them yet the point is
maybe the phones are trash no one's
actually done any forensic analysis on
these things no one's actually run
through them the media just lies yes
yeah about everything trump's truth
social may be sued over apparent breach
of open source terms that's from uh
washington exam bro it's not even out
yet it says may be facing too it doesn't
say exactly that's up to me well that's
how they get you this might happen this
may be the thing again uh where's the
facts where's the resources where's the
people actually coming out and standing
behind a statement almost every
statement you see in the mainstream
media now is sources said or officials
said you can't believe any of those
people based on the screenshots i have
seen it absolutely is based on mastodon
i didn't realize screenshots was were
forensic evidence yeah exactly of course
exactly so you can't jump the gun on
this stuff yeah no i'm reading uh and
now in this moto article yeah oh gizmodo
bastian's of great journalism i mean
it's not like it i'm not making it up is
what i'm saying yeah i know but like
maybe when they actually launch the
platform we can make a determination
about what they're doing with open
source and whether or not they're filing
any licenses this comes from the people
that are in the beta i think is
if they if they if they're not even if
it's not even publicly available have
they violated any license i don't know
about the answer is no yeah most people
talking about trump are are deranged or
mentally defunct in many different ways
and they go into this fervor where they
literally start connecting dots that are
not there and again not a trump fan
people know i'm not a trump fan but
let's be honest here a lot of the news
around him has been absolutely fake and
because that fake news it galvanizes and
double downs his audience to support him
that much more and if they were just you
know honest and real and tried to
actually do some legitimate reporting
maybe we could have criticized him on
actually the bad things he did because
he wasn't a perfect president he did
some bad things but there was no way to
even criticize him doing bad things
because everyone was just screaming like
other idiots so this guy
michael talon says was able to set up an
account using the handle donald trump on
truth social former president trump's
new website although the site is not
officially open a url was discovered
allowing users to sign up anyway that
sounds like a violation of the computer
fraud and abuse act yeah let's see if
the feds actually go after any of these
people for doing that it's a dumb law by
the way i don't want him to but if if
you if you get a url that you are not
allowed to access and then use it anyway
and try that's actually illegal dumb law
by the way i bring it up because the
government would absolutely go after
anybody who dares oppose the
establishment these people are they're
mocking trump so it'll be totally fine
but that being said how can you violate
a license if the website isn't publicly
open and people are breaking in
yeah a very good point that i'm happy
i'm just i just can't stand it's all
lies all the time
the trump derangement syndrome is real i
mean we all know people who they just
they wake up every morning imagine
letting a guy like that live rent free
in your brain it's it's it's really
fascinating because
it's like you think about it like this
is like i always look at trump as like
the uh well okay you got to figure out
what may what makes people so upset
about trump right it's because he holds
people accountable he's a lot he's a
loudmouth he's like the guy at the end
of the bar that's drunk saying that he
knows how to fix the country i mean like
look i look at him as like the guy from
bar rescue you guys ever watched that
show bar rescue it's a guy that fixes
bars up he's a guy from long island like
a big you know big buffalo looking guy
from long island people he's just like
he's like a trump right so i don't care
what that guy says i don't care what
what kind of skeletons he has in his
closet just fix my bar just like like
with trump just fix the country i don't
care i don't need a daddy up there
that's why i feel like a lot of these
people that hate trump so much who loved
obama so much and they love kamala and
biden all that what do they all have in
common they talk to you like children
they want a daddy they want to feel good
they want everything to be cozy whereas
trump held like said look the world's a
jungle you know what i mean it's like
like there's a lot of problems we got to
take this guy out we got to do this we
got it's holding people accountable it's
keep it's putting people
you know it's personal accountability
which is which is lost i think he held
people accountable for his actions
whereas like you have biden up there on
a fake stage you know what i would
like a marinette whatever puppet strings
above him and he's reading the
teleprompter he can't even get through a
sentence after they have the time oh i
mean
talking back about mastodon i'll tell
you what my criticism of trump is yeah
mastadon's open source
they they they want and encourage people
to create different versions different
rules i i you know i pulled it up opens
free and open source self-hosted social
networking micro blogging similar
twitter blah blah blah
it's not even public yet tr uh trump
hasn't released this they found a url to
break in
maybe when he publishes he won't put the
license you know credit or whatever in i
don't know it's not the point right now
the point is why are they mad about this
yeah why are they mad at someone for
taking the code and using it and more
importantly why can't trump just build
something well they're mad because it's
a gpl license and if you take gpl and
make it private you're violating gps
because you made it private uh if you
don't attribute gpl
it hasn't even launched it yet right the
point is that's why trump didn't even do
anything and they're like he's using
mastodon it's like you want people to
use it it's open source that's the point
no it's not yeah
software is different than open source
imagine if with with uh open network we
were like we've created this great
application people to use and then as
soon as someone we didn't like use it we
were like oh oh i can't believe someone
i don't like is using the free software
we made it's if they make it proprietary
without i mean that's not happening
right now that's my point they're using
that as an excuse to be mad and nothing
has happened it's not even out it's not
publicly available and they're acting
like the apocalypse has already occurred
i know this says that they they in truth
socials claims that all source code is
proprietary that's a claim that
apparently when when when trump takes it
public and that's there then by all
means we should we should we should
definitely talk about it yeah then you
could criticize it trump could cure
cancer and they'd say doctors are losing
jobs it's because trump is back you guys
they get a chance to write 50 million
stories about how he's screwing
everything up already this site's not
even open and they're jumping down his
throat for what they have absolutely no
evidence they have screenshots they got
into a url they weren't supposed to get
into and they're like oh my gosh trump's
doing everything wrong oh really like
you were telling us for the past they
realized this backfires now we're all
interested in this right exactly
well
to add to your point uh joey there trump
definitely kind of represents the tough
father and the democrats kind of
represent the deranged crazy cat lady
that smells like pee
in my opinion because they're just like
totally unhinged totally not talking
about the topics and they're trying to
blame everything on trump trying to
blame everything on the dad trying to
blame everything on him him him him him
and again he he made some mistakes i
criticized him throughout his presidency
i think he deserved some criticism but
none of that criticism was even heard uh
because of the insanity that was created
by these people that literally had no
talking points no basis to even attack
him on daddy issues exactly the silver
lining here is if he is using a mastodon
fork that means it's part of the
fetiverse which means that if he opens
up the code which you're supposed to do
then we can integrate with it this is
really great this is this is good yeah
yeah the fetaverse is basically uh let
me read this uh to you guys about
mastodon what trump's social network
basically does they say uh for mastodon
gab a controversial network blah blah
blah far right changed its software
platform to a fork of mastodon and
became the largest mastodon node in july
2019 that's right
mastodon the biggest node is gab
in response mastodon's main contributors
stated in their blog they were
completely opposed to gaap's project of
philosophy criticized gab they blocked
the content saying it was all racist or
whatever but they could only block it
from their servers what that means is
truth that's social if trump gets it up
and running and you have an account on
it
maybe mastodon says we're banning
trump's platform but they can't ban you
this is good news especially for the
stuff we're working on using the
fetiverse
we're getting away from the centralized
control of communications no more
zuckerberg would just ski or whatever
dorsey deciding to nuke your account
because it'll be your private website
services can decline service to you but
you can always find an alternative where
there's real competition so this is this
is good this is good stuff good good job
trump i agree
you